what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch from a channel that has
awesome list videos it's been a while
since we just covered a good old list
video about movies that's not solely
comic book related or godzilla
that is from the things there are other
movies
i think so this is 20 scenes where
actors
weren't acting a bunch of lazy ass
people
didn't bother to prepare no that's not
what it's about
please base off the thumbnail shots
fired the video
it's your grandma what
yeah one of the best parts of a
blockbuster movie or a hit tv series
is the behind the scenes bloopers that
have fans laughing until they cry
but what about the bloopers that
actually make it into the final cut
welcome back the things fans have you
ever thought you caught a glimpse of an
actor laughing
super serious scene or caught a moment
on screen that looked a little too real
to be acting
yes jobs are to bring characters to life
and make them seem like real people
well the truth is that a lot of the time
actors do this by being real
and hellhouse yeah
robin williams himself buckle up this
could get real
okay let's see what's in store a
stranger things cast may be at the
beginning of their careers
that's an interview they were not acting
there
possessed billy she's so tired that she
falls back into michael
but we discovered that millie bobby
brown actually broke character in this
scene and is the one who fell back into
finn
this scene was so intense that even she
was exhausted
if you look closely really finn glancing
at the directors and concerned because
he totally wasn't expecting oh
dang
that's beautiful whenever they do that
with like great dramatic moments i mean
yeah looking at this moment we'll first
like what the hell do i do
what do i do i'm not used to going off
book do we keep going i mean that's the
mark of great acting but
that's also the benefit of having
handheld camera work too
is when you can actually follow your
directors like that if that is
true they must have had two cameras set
up which is kind of unusual for certain
scenes like this
especially to have one be like coming
off to the left and this one coming
straight down like that they must have
had the ability to at least
move pretty fast because i could imagine
also them just going ah damn this was
too good we gotta cover it quick yeah
yeah yeah handheld lets you do that oh
that's beautiful hell yeah millie bobby
brown my
nola homes a creepy killer clown is bad
enough through a screen
imagine seeing one in real life that's
exactly what happened to the cast of the
i did hear about this i did hear about
this yeah i did not
separate from bill skarsgard when he was
in his full pennywise makeup and costume
i think we all also decided mutually
that it would be good to see him for the
first time and
just be freaked out the first time they
saw him altogether was when they were
filming the infamous projector scene
i didn't know it was that's what i don't
know i didn't know it's that scene
how they do that but what so wait a
minute
how does that even work
i remember he pops out it's like this
big cgi effect i don't remember
him like actually showing up in that
scene though they waited to reveal
an image to them oh fetty wise probably
won't stop for all these
it wasn't friends at first sight for
this superhero duo
in fact it took quite a while for tony
stark to warm up
i believe this was in the other list
video we watched between the two was
nothing but awkward and it's all thanks
to tom holland breaking character
that's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
door for you we're not we're not there
yet or
or he was so in character trying to be
funny and robert downey jr's line
afterward about opening the car door is
him trying to save the scene
i'm trying to save the damn seat the
seat's not working
dollars on the line with robert downey
jr
i don't want to go
and made not only the characters but the
actor's emotions more real
tom hall in decimated away was it acting
here's a reason why isla fisher's
character henley looks like she's really
drowning during one of her
oh no no
she was actually drowning luckily
nothing went terribly wrong
and we got the awesome scene that ended
up in the final cut
how did she hold on a second
what the hell she was actually drowning
i'm a
tad confused by the statement here it's
one thing to be doing your own
stunt and then you go underwater and
yada yada or would there something
actually go wrong with the stunt where
she was stuck under there for a while
and trying to get out and she was kind
of in a scream
tube situation yeah over this whole
crowd
everyone's watching her and they're like
man she's doing a great job
i feel like probably what happened is
they just actually chained her in there
and had some kind
of professional around in case anything
should go wrong and then she just
did the stunts yeah unless yeah there's
another uh
layer where she'd actually get stuck
start running out of breath
and they had to like dismantle the stunt
really fast yeah it's very believable
in that moment would you ever take on a
role in a horror series
even if we told you yes some directors
purposely scare actors on camera to get
a genuine reaction
this exact thing happened during a scene
for the hit netflix show the haunting of
hill house
actress victoria pedretti pops her head
out the backseat of a car in order to
scare her two sisters
but during one take she did it earlier
than expected
that's smart sir are completely real
that's smart that's cool probably why
that's such a memorable moment that's
great too because that is the scariest
moment of that whole
season like yeah it's one of the best
jump scares of all time is that jump
scare
do you remember kevin's electric
performance of tear me down in
riverdale's season nope never saw that
episode
what kevin's actor casey cott and kj
appa teamed up to shock the other app oh
wow kevin kisses archie it was totally
unscripted and it makes the look of
shock on everyone
go kevin
while kj was of course punching him so
painful he still managed to break his
hand while filming the scene
this isn't real ice jesus hurts
work went into the film we're not
surprised one shocking fact about the
film
is that sandra bullock really was
blindfolded during her scenes
and actually couldn't see that means
mountain stumbling around on the scene
wasn't all acting
it was very real it's really good not
being able to see acting right there
ray charles jamie foxx he had contacts
and that would actually make him blind
when he was on set
as well the other part too with the
physicality one that's a pretty common
one aragorn
and the two towers when he kicked the
helmet after he thinks mary and pippen
are dead
that he actually like broke his toe in
that shot and that's the screaming and
agony shot that you use
and then he knows like jake gyllenhaal
nightcrawler and all that and the
dicaprio and jango and she you know the
joker film was nothing short of
spectacular
and a lot of it is thanks to joaquin
phoenix there's actually an iconic scene
included in the movie that was all
thanks to joakim's emotions and not
acting at all
one day on set he got to hear the
soundtrack to the film for the first
time
his lone tears oh the dance oh reaction
to hearing the music
i thought it was the i thought it was
the bathroom i thought you might be
wrong about that
yeah i believe it was the dancing yeah
because you just
yeah they didn't even have a scene
written for that if it was their actors
lana and noah having fun
if you pay attention to the film lara
jean's lock screen is actually her and
peter napping
but according to the director the photo
on her phone was actually taken
of lana and noah napping together in
between takes oh
what did you just feel
about them that we didn't know about is
that what just happened there
right man get that gossip going get that
guy i don't remember hearing anything
about them dating i've seen both of
those movies they're just getting into
character
they're not acting but act
any kid would be scared of maleficent
we're even scared of maleficent
that's why for not angelina jolie's work
as toddler aurora was angelina jolie's
daughter vivian
the acting in their adorable scenes
that's her real daughter
and her mother's attention malfoy that's
cute
so when we see malfoy stop his friend
from clapping after a gryffindor victory
we think nothing of it but the scene is
actually tom felton stopping his co-star
from clapping because he knew he wasn't
supposed to
tom was really trying to keep cool calm
and collaborative oh that's a beautiful
mistake
that's such a beautiful mistake and it's
so within those characters
yeah it works so well for the scene for
him to do that but i love that he's
trying to actually but no no you're not
supposed to clap man but it works so far
that is a great mistake that's a gift
right there
grey's anatomy has been around for years
so the actors have gotten pretty good at
their jobs
but of course they still break character
every now and again
in this scene jessica capshaw decided to
improv a kiss between her and camilla
luddington
this shock on joe's face is 100 camilla
michael scott's last episode of the
office was extremely emotional for the
characters but it was also hard for the
actors to say goodbye to steve carell
that's why in the scene where pam rushes
to the airport to say goodbye to michael
the emotional performance by jenna
fisher wasn't a performance
at all let's see oh my god no
whoa we cannot spoil check us on patreon
we made it to season seven reaction
highlights full-length watcher longs are
included there definitely didn't see
that episode of supernatural
we're talking about no spoilers let's go
back now
all right jason segel had no idea that
his character marshall would be losing
his father in the series
in fact the first time he found out was
when allison hannigan's character
told him the his emotions to finding out
the news
wow that is that's bold jason siegel
and alice and hannah for that matter
like a very very natural way to handle
it i would have broke character i'm like
what the [ __ ]
that's not a script
david schwimmer managed to pull off a
practical joke on jennifer aniston while
filming friends
and it was used in an episode he along
with his sidekick cole sprouse pretended
like he had fallen down
but it was really only a dummy jennifer
had no idea it was going to happen
so oh really i never knew that
he was freaking out oh i love that
moment the moment's so funny
genius in good will hunting during a
therapy scene with matt damon
he tells him a hilarious story about the
flatulence problem his character's wife
had
the story was so funny because it was
completely made up by robin
matt damon's smiles and laughs are all
real pretty that's
great that's great today we still strive
to have the aesthetic julia roberts
brought to that screen
we're here to tell you that one of the
most iconic scenes was
in fact completely unscripted when julia
roberts gets her hand caught in the
jewelry box that richard gere closes
her reaction wasn't acting she had no
idea that he was going to do that
at all what can we say
i look so genuine yeah i look so genuine
to imagine what these movies and series
would look like without some of these
scenes
completely different right richard
toying with that girl i'd let him slap
my hand with a jewelry box
well i liked this video a lot the things
i guess the one that is the most
surprising is also the most questionable
whether or not it was
what's the freaking moment what isle of
fisher drowning
a lot of them are really cool i mean
even with a haunting a hill house
but the jump scare did bring me back to
in the movie hatchet that horror film
there was a take
where the guy who plays crowley in that
oh
kane hotter yeah um
i hope that question comes up in the
show down for you so yeah thanks to
he would always stay in character to
scare them but there was one take they
did
where he had a dummy axe and they told
they told the actors that the axe was
real the entire time
and then he threw the axe at them at one
point and they were all under the
impression that that was a real
accident they were freaking out yes
that's traumatized that's actually
really messed up
that's the thing is there's a thin line
especially on these horror movies that's
where
you know getting people out and uh
depending on the context that could be
pretty grim
same thing with luke skywalker getting
the information and empire strikes back
of i am your father he didn't know that
was going to be the line told to him
they hide the father reveals apparently
from actors
uh yeah i feel like you can make like a
zillion of these lists actually oh yeah
the comment thread has to be
jumped in on this video all right guys
well
what do you think about this did any of
these shock you i like these kind of
videos i really like i really miss more
i
want to cover a little more list videos
subscribe to the things you may have
done so already subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell hit
that like button and last but not least
fox john specifically chose you to shout
out and i've been the one who's been
talking to you and patreon messages
so i'm yeah very curious sending
me badass tunes and helping me
keep up on some good ass television
and uh fox 2 has been inspiring me
because in 2021 i want to get a little
bit of a better handle on my
fitness in life and i know that fox you
are super athletic
and also i mean you could probably beat
me up honestly because like you know
this
boxing and stuff did you read our
conversations it's possible i might have
looked in on some of your conversations
with many of the patrons here at patreon
it's not only in the comments that i can
see your thoughts
but either way i mean i'm not even lying
because like
we used to take martial arts back in the
day and i am very much out of practice
with that but part of me was like maybe
some type of boxing endeavor could be an
easy way to jump back into that let me
read your text messages
sure which ones what just here take my
phone
[Music]